[Music]  everybody of course knows Thanksgiving  is next week but this is interesting did  you know that this year true story  Thanksgiving falls on the same day as  the first day of Hanukkah really okay  yeah this is an occurrence that will not  happen again for another 80,000 years  seriously that's pretty amazing yeah we  found out about this we want to  celebrate this very rare coincidence by  bringing out a character who we feel  embraces both holidays equally please  welcome the Thanksgiving turkey dreidel  [Applause]  anybody playing dreidel at home this is  the time to place your bets will it be  shin-hye gimel or noon all right ready  set go  [Applause]  Oh  that's that's great I think if you look  at the slow motion you might detect in  the spinning that the turkeys head  momentarily  being losing the beautiful illusion it's  very convenient though to find a self  decapitating Turkey dance though his dad